a rebel nation we have got some prizes
to give we've got some prizes to give
away on the tour because what is it tour
without some fun prizes there's gonna be
a lot of them that we announce
welcome to announce to today and there's
gonna be one at least one that I
announce every week new prizes some of
them are pretty awesome until the actual
tour launches timo we're making very
serious video right now very serious
video we're giving away some awesome
prizes we're going to group these prizes
into three categories those acute yarn
one is price that everybody gets so if
you buy ticket you get this prize just
for buying the ticket on top of getting
to come out to the event to our prizes
for each city so one person each city
will get a prize and then the third
category is for the whole tour grand
prizes one person who bought a ticket
for the whole tour somebody that makes
it for the whole tour this one this one
prize for the whole tour right if I take
it you're entered into the raffle yeah
grand prize a bunch of grand prizes
okay before getting to the prizes
announcements updates updates updates
how we doing what's happening in the
tour right now it's still a bit chaotic
I'm gonna be honest we're making updates
to the website
pretty much every day yeah still making
some design changes still putting some
content up there I'm so humbled and
amazed that people are buying tickets
without even knowing where they're going
yet every day we get notifications
somebody from Cincinnati bought two
tickets somebody from Pittsburgh but
another ticket and it's amazing and
people have no idea where they're going
yet right it's shocking but it's awesome
you guys are awesome keep doing that
that we love it so we're working with
you know the the whole idea of charging
and having a
a venue obviously shifted since my
original intention so we don't have a
lot of time to plan Nina and a buddy of
mine Louis from a company called
last-minute training are doing the work
of booking the different venues so we're
close on Pittsburgh by the time this
video comes out we probably figured out
Pittsburgh oh my god hope we figured out
Pittsburgh no and then and then what
work out the others and as soon as we
have information we will be updating on
the website so go check that out but
it's gonna be in that in the area so I
just I love it I love that people bought
the tickets without that's like how much
love they have oh yeah people are so
nice the people riding in like the
effort that they want to help people
want to help people want to buy tickets
without ever knowing it's amazing I love
it I love the leaf nation I think we're
asked what else we doing Nina has
officially quit her job and had her
first day on the job
how's that going you know Nina is now in
a job where she has to work really hard
add the word now tends to break every
time whenever some emails writing of
course what are we doing here with work
we're changing lives this is a serious
business
weekend everybody works on weekends okay
[Music]
okay so you got your first day on the
job that's awesome oh she made a
gigantic mistake it's not kind of not
ready
total disaster the whole thing with them
deleted something on Facebook that
crashed the entire face advantage event
page so nobody could see the schedule or
get access so this is our Friday night
so we created a brand new she felt
really bad she's on the verge of tears
but you know what this is a good lesson
so we've worked so hard on building this
page and we put it up and finally some
people are now like going buying tickets
and then BOOM crash gone and and you
can't contact Facebook to tell them
what's up and he knows a very upset very
saddened by this and I'm I'm now like oh
my gosh are you kidding me but it's but
so much time but I don't mind natural
reaction to bad news is not to not to
like take it out on somebody wasn't like
you saw oh my god I can't believe this
happen okay we're gonna fix this we go
to the computer and I put on some music
put on some happy music pull out some
Chicago makes popcorn start snacking is
like we're gonna fix it and we did
but anyway everything is fixed it's all
working now but that was Nina's first
day okay what else first day on the job
anything else to share there's minor
stuff well not a minor figure out the
Internet's there you know internet if
you guys have suggestions my ideal
situation is to drive between cities
obviously we're driving and I want to
have my meetings I want to do I want to
still be able to do my my beautiful my
team but also podcast interviews
Hangouts Skype the usual stuff that I do
but I'm worried about the internet
dropping off on the long drives in
between the big cities and so if you
have suggestions for weather
hot spot whether we do send cards which
provider how do we make it happen so
that we can keep consistent internet and
if I'm booking meetings with people to
do IG lives that it doesn't crash
halfway through or super slow connection
which is gonna be frustrating and
embarrassing yeah they're all right now
they save them I look at all the
variables Verizon has the best network
all right for you well if you have if
you guys have suggestions feedback let
us know if you have anything for us to
do in the city or think we should meet
or or eat or where to eat anything any
suggestions for the tour if you email
tour at Evan Carmichael calm it goes to
her so be nice she's picking it up and
responded personally and I've also told
her that she needs to be nice on the
emails as well
she's very corporate
she's very corporate I made a corporate
job for what this is this is not a
corporate audience these are this is
these are our friends over here so
somebody writes in and says hey how do
we do this she's like you do this thank
you for writing in it means so much to
us we can't wait to meet you you know
like love you one would just care we got
it we need if you do not if you write in
the toward Evan Carmichael comm with an
amazing suggestion and you do not get
care yeah if you do not feel the care
coming back in the response email me
[Laughter]
we'll fix this
it's been crazy yeah I feel like we
probably missing some stuff but anyway
we're moving quick moving quick we're
launching for launching I'm so again
like humbled amazed can't wait to meet
you guys the feedback energy has been so
positive and as soon as we get locations
will you know and again can't wait to
meet you
ok prizes prizes and then we're gonna
read your feedback and react to it from
last week's video
so prizes again we're gonna do prizes
for everybody who buys a ticket for one
per city and and then grand prizes one
for the whole tour so the two that we're
gonna announce today is one everybody
who buys a ticket also gets a free
coaching session with coach Lilly so
that's a hundred dollar value us coach
Lily's been a part of the team for two
years had a major impact and a lot of
entrepreneurs she's a big part of the
workshop that I do in Toronto as well
and people have had some significant
breakthroughs in dealing with her
one-on-one and it's a Skype session so
it could be wherever you are in the
world awesome she'll be able to to help
you with it and so she has has committed
to me a ton of effort for her and part
of why I love her so much she's
committed that everybody who buys a
ticket ticket starts at 45 bucks oh
that's awesome
there's also we talked with the prices
right like it's 45 bucks for one or we
could buy two seventy-five seventy-five
or three for 90 95 so if you buy three
it's ends up losing anything for the
price of two yeah pretty much yeah so if
you bring a friend you get in everybody
save some money but basically if you're
buying one ticket for 45 bucks you get
to spend the night with me bring your
questions we're gonna make it count it's
gonna be an amazing evening and now
you're also gonna get a free Skype
session with coach Lilly hundred dollar
value whether you want to do that before
the event happens or you want to wait
until we meet in your city and then you
have a follow up questions or you want
to go further you can book a session
with Coach Lilly
and so that's an amazing value that
everybody is going to get just for
buying a ticket if you find two tickets
with a friend then you both get one or
you could take both sessions for
yourself and screw your friends over or
you just really need two sessions you
know you can do that too so that's for
everybody who buys a ticket I'm also
gonna throw in a what was the third tier
the gray one grand prize is gonna be a
ticket to my workshop in Toronto in May
so twice a year I do a workshop in
Toronto on how to make money as a
thought leader so I believe that you are
a genius you're a thought leader the
world needs to hear your ideas and if
you want to be the me of your industry
you want to make money from workshops
and seminars and book deals and brand
deals and YouTube and Instagram build
your following and sell your products
and services that's what we do for three
days it's pretty intense it's a $2,000
ticket and I'm there's a two-day it's
fifty four fifty hundred and the
three-day is 2,000 yeah you get you get
the full three-day pass it's a really
life-changing experience changing its
feels hollow to say just it feels Jesus
is a life-changing experience but I give
ridiculous amounts like I got sick for a
week after doing that and was living off
the fumes and as was the whole team but
it's uh it's an unforgettable experience
you're gonna come away with not just
ideas but but but execution but we're
gonna be doing work together very
hands-on so it's only 15 people max 15
people max and I'm gonna give one of
those tickets away to somebody on this
tour so everybody gets to the coaching
session Lily hundred dollar value and
one person's gonna get the two thousand
dollar ticket to join me in May yourself
to pay for your flight I guess to get
here and here be be able to tell but the
two thousand dollars ticket is on me and
I'm looking forward to spending an
intense three days with you guys okay so
those are the two big prize
announcements this week in future weeks
every week demo go
every week we're going to be announcing
more prizes until the tour launches but
now we're going to get some of your
comments from last week see what you
guys said we're gonna react to it
hopefully it's not too crazy let's see
let's see let's see I was I'm really
nervous at making this fear that's a
title I was really nervous the nerves
are starting to get easier we're kind of
getting into it but but I imagine that
like as we get close to it like oh my
god we're driving to Pittsburgh
tomorrow's event it's gonna be a fun
tour to watch
we'll keep filming it will do IG lives
ok comments comments oh we got me huh
bill congratulations Dina I'm leaving
her job putting that hoodie on and
hitting the road with that thank you
nice okay I would smart Network this is
such a huge and amazing effort Evan
you're pushing the things you do for
this community to a whole new level I
hope so you know that this is something
that might be the greatest thing of all
time and we do it every year and just
pick different parts of the world to go
and do it with or some one-time thing
it's like I took everything we had and
we're done and we're never doing it
again
yeah buy the ticket so you can keep
doing it we're coming to your city but
we won't come back to the same cities
right like Minnesota and Pittsburgh in a
bunch these places we've never been to
like I may never go back unless there's
another event or something if we do the
tour will be different parts of the
world so like this is the one time I'm
coming your city let's make it count
together
oh no no Florida having such enemies in
person go to you from facing your fears
you're a very brave Florida if we do it
again in 2020 it'd be East Coast so we
do Florida for sure and hit all the
cities down the east coast from Texas
would be the furthest west and we would
go east coast but depends all your
Floridians if you wanted to happen in
2020 you gotta you gotta tell your
friends out west the cities are going to
get your tickets
best of luck if I was living in the USA
would come see for sure thank you cut
Jana I you don't make
go overseas in 2021 if it works out
Prairie Dodgers no worries it's the best
a NEMA is even better name is getting
love you get love in the chat can you be
nice to people on email at least you
know you didn't so much love okay
Deborah Davis it love the name of the
tour it's also really inspiring to see
you're doing something that you have
never done before and facing your fears
I mean really really inspiring
University surprised me with your
overall attitude approach to life Evan
I'm also glad to know you have people in
your life who continue to push you and
support your goal mission and vision
yeah you know this this happened because
my agent pushed me in New York well two
things happen in New York when we did
the meet up out of coffee shop and it
was too too busy too many people and it
wasn't a good experience and I'm I'm
trying to yell her head no microphone
and I have my back to a whole bunch of
people and it's just as we've grown
we haven't I can't just keep doing
coffee shops or oh it's like some really
exclusive thing do in a coffee shop
interestingly not my first meetup ever
definitely this my first meetup ever
with fans was in New York way back like
six years ago or something I sucked
looking box i don'ti don't know the date
but my first was in New York and an
email everybody in my list who's in New
York to say hey I'm coming in New York
why don't we meet up and I think like
five people said yes and like boom so
nervous gonna be five people is the
first time this is crazy people meet
your Ned what's gonna happen and then
for them canceled on me for them
cancelled within a week of it happening
so they did so that is okay no one
person whatever I'll make the one person
and we had a meetup location in Times
Square and then and then like I'm
sitting there waiting and then they
message me I can't buy myself in Times
Square
[Music]
so said nobody showed up to my meetups
but then we had this one in New York and
it was great right like Phil filled the
place lots of good times good vibes but
again like no microphone people couldn't
hear me and so I mean the lesson from
that as a kept going right like they
kept doing meetups and we kept kept
doing even though the first person was
traumatic but it was great to have that
happened and then to meet my I met my
agent basically right after like I left
the meetup to go meet him for a quick
bite and that's when he said that I
played small and I should be charging
for this stuff like okay I'm ready I'm
ready I'm ready to play a bigger game so
yes having people in your life to push
you whether those are people
face-to-face or videos I gotta get
pushed a lot still by Elon Musk and
Steve Jobs and Oprah and the videos that
I watch and create so otherwise you'd
stay where you are you know and you
don't want to be in the same spot that
you are a year from today and the only
difference will be the people that
you're hanging out with and the
information that you're consuming DJ
come on Evan what's your one word
believe' I'm scared too I've spent way
too much time holding back what needs to
be done because fear has crippled me for
so long let's do this you'll do just
fine so my one word is believe and
whatever your one word is when you find
it it just the problems that you have
faced in the past we're still around
belief for me and it never goes away
you're just able to conquer and fight
bigger monsters so believe what's always
gonna be something that I need in my
life it's always gonna be a challenge
and so whenever you figure out your one
word is it gives you the clarity gives
it the path it gives you the direction
it's your compass it's your light but
you never fully conquer it
you're just able to go off and slay
bigger demons and bigger monsters and so
yes like people ask me on interviews
what would I tell my 19 year old self
and see will believe more but the mind
twist that I always add to it is an 85
year old Evan coming back to today's
Evan would say the same thing believe
more
and so I'm never done believe in to
myself there's always a new level that I
have to get to it's the greatest
strength and also the greatest weakness
so yes my lumber is believed and I need
to remind myself of that every day happy
facts lifestyle well I heard you're
gonna be busy but didn't realize this is
whatever was sounds from it all thank
you for the love Suzy we believe you're
gonna crush these events you'll get them
Thank You Nick well done Evan from the
UK encourages inspiring just be you
you're great and your work is very
valuable and empowering people globally
sending you love like positive vibes oh
and have fun enjoy Elsa - Nina xx thank
you and this this also helps write like
the love and the comments here is great
the emails that Nina's getting is great
all your emails to me your DMS the the
the feedback and encouragement is
amazing I mean it doesn't mean that it's
gonna work out and we're gonna sell it
at the event but but the momentum is
awesome and the love that you guys are
bringing us is really awesome
diva Montana from Indiana Indiana we're
going it we're going to Nina I think you
should have people sign up that way you
know what's isolation e for each city
yes the challenge there is we need to
book places in advance
yeah right we you know if it gets to be
too big then we could probably can
always sell out the tickets that's a
great problem to have or try to find a
bigger venue but but going down or
canceling is using not an option like
we're looking at this trip right now I
have to put a deposit down and I've like
paid for the place and so I have to pay
for the place whether one person shows
up or everybody shows up so that's a
challenge and booking out bad news I
don't like like it's amazing that people
are buying tickets without knowing where
it is but I don't think that's gonna be
most people most people would want to
know like if I am buying a ticket for an
event I kinda want to know where I'm
going we're going right Steven Harris
you're you are now practicing what you
preach you'll be fine much love I'll be
praying for you pastor Steve appreciate
that man really appreciate that
Christina yeah we'll see you in
Sacramento yeah
steena see you in Sacramento Christina
I'm excited
Ashish Avenue Rock nothing nervous about
about you brother
your videos are inspirational and as a
result I also care about that YouTube
channel thank you for encouraging being
impacted in my life in many ways
awesome I'm still nervous I think
nervous is good I think it means you
should be doing that thing
everything greats on the other side of
your nerves so let's go Nathaniel Morton
just bought my ticket for the Pittsburgh
event
yeah I'm Nathaniel we love you man see
you in Pittsburgh now I gotta think of a
great question ask
that's right Nathaniel bring your great
questions we want to answer them I love
it man
next Vita Evan it will all work out well
don't warrant is jumping in the joy PS
most very grateful for Nina for her
complete support I hope you tell her so
I really this has to be friends okay
okay well this your price day my heart
says I'm very grateful for your complete
support yeah it's pretty amazing to have
Dean on board you know that Nina loves
this started because Nina I told him I
go ticket every city in North America
with the million plus people and she
also loves organizing and I hate all of
the all of the planning around it I hate
booking venues and all of that stuff is
not what I enjoy doing but Nina loves
doing it I thought about actually having
an event management business or job at
one point so this is now it this is now
your job it's amazing yeah so I'm very
good okay well you feel the love you see
if you the love okay what else
Valerie you got this Nina Devin hope to
come to st. Louis Missouri yes we're
coming to st. Louis we can see you there
Valerie get your ticket and finally meet
you I know what it means being nervous
speaking with a large crowd of people
and we may as well get ready and accept
it that was bound to happen eventually
you you got this and I'll pray for you
if you will pray for me
you're my hero and I need to be on this
tour with you
awesome Valerie well I'm looking forward
to meeting you speaking in front of a
large crowd is awesome used
that I'm wit but these still aren't
going to be large large crowds right
it's an intimate location in every venue
in each city so I've spoken in front of
thousands of people national TV
audiences and all that stuff that's not
what this is my bigger concern is that
hey we booked this venue when one person
shows up actually one person is worse
than no people like if no people show up
we go home but if one they're like three
people show up like oh well this is
pretty embarrassing okay but but there'd
be that awkward moment and then it would
actually end up being like the greatest
thing of all time at my very first
speaking gig that I did in Canada at the
YMCA only three people showed up and it
was the best because that actually got
me to continuing to speak because I I
just it's way more intimate right it's
just me and three peoples it's like a
private coaching session and they ended
up being changed that day and I thought
that's what convinced me like I need to
keep doing this helping entrepreneurship
thing but my big fear is I don't like
disappointing people or letting people
down so when I commit to somebody I make
sure that I do that thing that that I
said I was gonna do and so that's the
that's the thing that's always burning
for me is I don't want people to feel
disappointed
Oh or let down and so the positive side
of that is that I end up over delivering
so it'll be crazy amazing value for
everybody who shows up because if you
did not get value would destroy me so
much we're gonna make sure it happens
okay next Danielle there's something so
graceful about Nina Wow hello graceful I
am treated by her every time she Grace's
us with her presence I want to be like
you and I grew up Nina
here's to graceful women supporting
amazing men Wow so so tips for Danielle
on how to be graceful what do you got
he's supportive we support it
nina is very graceful and very
supportive and we love her you turning
right a little bit a little bit nervous
no it's hot in here that's why I'm
turning right it's not hot it's not that
hot in here this is nervous okay DJ
strange see you in Pittsburgh yes DJ
strains strains see you in Pittsburgh I
want to hear your music if you're a DJ
to let me know
Tyra bebe Congrats how do you find an
agent that's a whole other topic come up
to the tour and one of the stops and ask
that question because I'd love to go
further detail with you crafty B I would
have paid to talk to you in New York
when we met it was fantastic and I got
so much out of it as did my son you're
gonna be amazing but I tried to see the
price of your tickets and it just took
me to Facebook I couldn't see where to
buy the tickets I'll be following your
journey and wish you were coming back to
New York City so I could meet Nina -
Nina's getting tons of love as expected
in the chat so crafted B was one of the
people who came to the New York meetup
in the coffee shop that that we did and
she brought her son with her and that
was an amazing event for the issues you
had on Facebook we fixed that so you can
now buy the tickets through Facebook in
every city right it's all set up
initially it was a disaster because we
were trying to set up event bride and
the Facebook still had coffee shops and
anyway that disasters been fixed now we
see the figure out where we're gonna
host all these events so yes you go to
Facebook now you should have all three
price options for one ticket to ticket
three tickets yeah every city yes
- Nina that's when Nina rocks okay
sleeping elephant I will see you in San
Francisco Sacramento yes if I'm in the
country be in the country we want to
meet you sleeping elephant - Keary this
will be an amazing trip of a lifetime
that you both will look back to in years
to come and know you did the right thing
you will not fail all caps not fail
the mere fact you embark on this journey
makes you winners you'll be a blast
absolutely positively take care of both
of you and have a fantastic time that's
some love let's complete the heart
they're gonna pick the heart that's love
that's love there that's love
they're from from two kiri compared to
five awesome a Benina
Evan TQ an advice believe yeah I need
it's true
talked about it lava tracks my friends
please come to Charleston South Carolina
2020 if we do it again if 2019 goes well
then 2020 we're doing East Coast and
we'll hit will hit Charleston has a
million-plus people in the area yeah
should be should be on the list so yes
we will meet you but like come to
Pittsburgh
you know do little go on a road trip -
oh you East Coasters I'm yeast coast you
know go on a little mini vacation / road
trip and come meet your friendly
neighborhood believe man and his amazing
what are you gonna be super grace filled
superwoman yeah you guys can join us why
not you deserve a trip out west or
little north right Misha
congratulations to you Annina I'm in
Chicago definitely be meeting you guys
that March yeah nice also us here open
to help please let me know how it can be
of assistance I do have some resources
to get additional meeting space if you
like email need a little more details
god bless yes any any suggestions advice
that one day we're doing in the city
we I'm trying to fill my day so whether
it's definitely the event in the evening
but then during the day if it's doing
interviews or doing another speaking gig
somewhere we're totally open email Mena
tour at Evan chemical calm and in some
cities there's nothing yeah and so we
gotta find stuff and then in other
cities we might get too much stuff and
you gotta then balance yeah where I'm
gonna go
so that's Nina's job to figure out and I
don't
very exciting okay Chris Congrats great
decision and even if I'm not in the
states I wish all the best ones journey
think you let the fear go away and
choose to go with the flow breathe
Luthor Chris that's for you Chris thank
you for the love I'm sure that all the
spaces where you and Nina go will be
full of beautiful and driven people
looking forward to it yes Rico been
watching your videos from Dubai I love
that we should do do by 2022 come on
Rico tell all your friends in the west
coast to buy tickets so we can come to
Dubai in 2022
do you work as this very so much you're
really good at what you're doing
appreciate that man good luck on this
tour I'll share your videos to all my
friends and even strangers I love that
man Rick how are you gonna share the
videos and strangers I really like if
you make a video of you sharing my
videos with strangers that'd be amazing
I want to see we go like on the streets
of Dubai saying hey excuse me I love
this man believe nation around the world
super supportive people say like social
media comments are troll and negativity
but man you guys are the best
Dee Walker you'll be just fine the
cotton is awesome and you know your
stuff in the meantime may the force be
with you
I love that deal arca thank you aha Evan
of course people come to support you
look at all you've given if I were in
your country I would be the for sure
please America go out and support Evan
and Nina I love it
yeah I don't think anything for granted
right like yes hopefully bringing people
some value but I don't expect anybody to
to give it back you know what I
understand first for this is a good
check the people who can't do it either
for a bunch of reasons and so I'm still
super grateful for anybody who gets
involved who helps who comes who
supports who helps me or Nina along this
entire train Yuka mama wish good luck
you have such an awesome partner heaven
love Nina support right
any comment that you guys leave on this
video that involves Nina will probably
get read and featured in next week's
video just I'm just saying Anna love for
you to include southern states such as
my city Dallas Texas Dallas so we went
to Dallas earlier this year yeah just
the way the map works getting back to
Toronto we weren't able to do Texas but
if you do 2020 Dallas we're going back
shifter oh man I live in Pittsburgh but
I'll be out of town shifter same town
shifter
come on shifter or meet us in a
different city you like going out of
town anyway so Pablo join us in
Cleveland or Chicago or west coast like
come to California we're doing how are
you doing in California like five la
[Music]
it's 4:00
so shifter come up come out to some one
of them come out and say hi we're giving
Pittsburgh love so Pittsburgh shifter
come come give us love back brat Oh
woohoo hope to see you in March yes I
love a brat oh I don't know where you
are but March we're hitting a bunch of
cities so we'd love to see you there
it's gonna be an awesome tour keep on
making a positive difference in people's
lives
with what you do thanks Evan appreciate
that Brad Oh Munna Congrats were many
needing your steps of here in other
countries so please find it outside the
USA for the next year 2020 no no no no
2020 Minicozzi 2020 one would be outside
somewhere 2022 is gonna be divided if we
see some good pickup fun from him
telling his friends about tickets so
tell all your American friends to
support 2019 so that we can make 2021
overseas happen where we go 2021 I'm
thinking Europe but
we can take a boat you take a pole but
yes Nina wants to focus okay I get it I
hear you Skelly that's great Evan have
fun and enjoy shadow - Nina for quitting
her job she's committed to your dreams
and a great support lessons of both of
you peace you gotta shout it thank you
Skelly you get a shout out to it peace
back anonymous nation I think 90 days is
a very short time for 23 cities there's
so much to explore in just one city yeah
so that there's two parts of that one we
destroy cities pretty quickly and - yes
but otherwise would be on the road for
so our our kind of plan is around 40 s
in each city so we have a travel day to
get to the city then we've got okay tell
us what happens - tell them what happens
on each day no day we're gonna go out
toward the city Ethan local food and
what can do with peer working and then I
know we then at the next a week apart
connects it to next city
that's roughly what we're doing in every
city Nina's organizing everything it's
amazing I just show up and get told what
to do
Denise you and your team are the best
it'd be great if you're near my area
I'll be there for sure Denise check the
website hopefully become in your area
and if not come travel I feel like we
should do some kind of prize for people
who come from out of state
like whoever whoever comes the furthest
like kind of what do by a guy to come I
feel like if you're coming from a
different country or or at least a good
distance like the Florida people coming
to California or coming to Chicago I
feel like they deserve something special
let me know like if you guys are serious
out-of-towners out of the out-of-towners
not just neighboring state like you got
to be at least two states away and not
like the little cheap like you gotta
have
good distance we have said a minimum
design and now we're dry yeah it's got
to be significant yeah or out of country
who's gonna come in for one of the
events yeah yeah rush hour all these
people talking I want to do something
special so so let me know if you're
serious about it the first person who
doesn't I'm gonna do something special
or regardless if you buy ticket and you
and you email me to say I am I am from
at least three states over armed from
out of out of town we're gonna do
something I don't know what yet but it's
gonna be awesome
and then if more people want to do it
will look at leave a comment and we'll
look at these next week I'm pretty
pumped that'd be so how amazing would
that be his people fly into my workshop
from Europe and all over the place right
be cool if somebody flew in from Russia
or Dubai for the Pittsburgh event and
you get to see a city right gts tubes
love the energy and content on this
channel before committee the 20 plus
shows doesn't it make sense to try a few
charge defense first yes that's not what
we're doing because cuz we're crazy and
we're going big and we'll see Marcelo
next tour in Europe maybe but come to
this one and get us bonus prize Pasadena
comm get sponsors for each event yeah
we're not doing a great job of that if
anybody wants to help get sponsors for
the individual events either either for
each city or across the whole thing let
me know I'm working on a potential hotel
partner for some of the cities but
listen if you guys know somebody who
wants a sponsor or you're willing to
help out it has not been on our radar
but I would I would love it I would love
it we'll figure out a way to make it
special for you to even email Nina to
learn every character comm and we'd be
super appreciative the howling Chihuahua
Fresno love believe nation come to
Fresno California listen we're coming to
four places in California five four or
five places in gala
wanyan you don't have a big excuse this
I don't know what let's see where's
Fresno dragging it on hold on where is
Fresno we're coming to San Jose San Jose
is like 150 kilometers I mean with that
is a miles like 100 miles it's a two and
a half hour drive we're drying Fran
Tonto and we're going to San Diego come
on not a lot of stuff happens in San
Diego so I feel like howling the
Chihuahua should come to the San Diego
one what do you think Nina we both
agreed so buy your ticket anyway we'd
love to meet you thank you thank you
thank you for the love okay I think we
gotta ended there read a lot of comments
thank you guys so much for the love and
support final thoughts what do you got I
have my ticket I have tickets name is in
pitch mode she's in hardcore pitch motor
so recap dates are coming soon we're
figuring it out within the next couple
of weeks we should have hopefully most
of them done but at least the early ones
for sure you can buy one ticket two or
three discounts there's prizes that
we'll announce every single week the
prize for the whole thing with your 18
ounce is a ticket to come to my workshop
in May 2019 in Toronto two thousand
dollar value and there'll be more coming
up and then everybody who buys a ticket
also gets by a forty five dollar ticket
that's an expensive price if we get $100
coaching session with coach Lily that
will that will change your life so
Maureen house is coming soon leave your
thoughts your questions your suggestions
your comments in the comments below and
next week we will talk about them and if
you guys want to check out the website
you want to see what for coming to your
city you want to get your tickets in
early check out the link right there
next to us thank you guys for watching
continue to believe I'll see you next
week